Stewart Brand: I'm interested in another thing,
Stewart Brand: you've raised the question of all
this dystopian science fiction going on.
The so-called Golden Age of science fiction
was very upbeat, utopian...
Like "Star Maker" (by Olaf Stapledon),
which is as utopian as it gets.
And he was kind of a utopian socialist and whatnot.
Generational concerns seem to have this kind of
countervailing... they're like, I want to be the mirror to
the understandings that I grew up with.
The understandings that a lot of the
Golden Age folks grew up with
was a fucking World War that was truly awful.
It was really devastating. Talk about dystopia.
It burnt a lot of the major cities in the
world right to the ground.
They lived through that.
But the current dystopians didn't
grow up with anything like that.
They grew up with technology getting better and better.
The economics getting better and better.
All the Steven Pinker world getting better and better...
Childbirth is not killing women the way it
used to do all over the world.
Basically people getting out of poverty
is the main event in the world.
And these guys are going
"Woah, just a goddamn minute!"
And then telling the counter story. Is the
counter story part of what science fiction people do?
Bruce Sterling: I actually think we have a kind of
Soviet level of dystopia.
Sterling: Because if you went and hung out
in the Soviet Union
you can make the same arguments. It's like,
well, you know, actually there's more roads.
And like there's better buildings
And the food is improved a lot since World War II.
So you know why are you actually like happy
and upbeat about being a Soviet?
In the writers union they're rewarded for that:
"I wrote a great novel about a tractor,"
It really brought in the crops. you know, it's super.
But it was the lies that corroded people's morale.
I think that's our actual problem now.
People are dystopian because they know that the
major problems we face are being papered over.
We're not dealing with the problems that we have.
So there's a loss of legitimacy among institutions
and you've got people who basically are dystopian
but they're dystopian in the level of life Soviet guys mumbling black humor jokes to one another.
While avoiding the situation, right?
And I like to make historical analogies,
but they don't always work perfectly
or well. And there are a lot of people in Russia right now
who are actually pretty upbeat about the situation.
I mean they're proud.
They really feel like they're off their deathbed
and kind of, you know, laying out with two fists.
They're ethnonationalist Russian enthusiasts.
And a lot of them are Christian fundamentalists.
Orthodox Christian fundamentalists.
And they do this even though there's like a
snowstorm of official lies from the regime.
I mean they just lie about everything routinely.
Like guys with nerve gas in London.
I mean they're lying so openly
and with such brazen lack of good faith
that it's almost like gloating.
And they're actually gloating with the lies at this point.
Russians used to be the most dystopian sci-fi writers
especially if they escaped Russia.
Whereas now the most optimistic ones
are probably Chinese.
You would not want to go to China
and say "oh what a great place!"
Normally you would not say 'I'm going to China for like, the better way of life, that they have.'
The Chinese sci-fi writers are just
punching way above their weight right now.
This really is their Golden Age of science fiction.
And they're not writing dystopian stuff, in fact
they're writing just really pretty good novels.
I mean things that have emotional depth.
They've got vision, they're not comic book-y or stupid.
They're not serving the regime.
They're really littérateurs!
You know, like they can really do it.
They're in pretty good shape.
So, how are you gonna explain that?
I don't know. I don't have a grand theory.
But it interests me a lot that they're around.
And they're not utopian.
The utopia thing is overblown.
People who wrote commercial science fiction
tended to write stuff with upbeat endings.
Especially in the US.
But the best-known works of imaginative fantasy are
"1984," "Brave New World," and other very serious, somber kind of geopolitical novels
that are all about oppression, torture and official lies.
And deceit and hate and murder and phoniness.
These are the things that are really
sunk down on a cultural level.
You see "Orwellian" around. You see "Ballardian" around. You don't really see "Buck Rogers-ian."
It just seems childish.
So, I don't know. It's a matter of temperament.
Guys of my era, I mean cyberpunks,
we're into dark euphoria.
We're not into a sense of wonder.
We're into ecstasy and dread.
I mean ecstasy and dread is stuff that
you see a lot in cyberpunk texts.
It's really horrible. But really really amazing!
And also really horrible.
But like just fantastic I can't get my head around it.
Except his leg's been sawn off.
And this is kind of a very deliberate period sensibility
that sort of emerged from the 1980s.
And you could see it in film,
and the way people dressed...
and that kind of thing. And, it was fun to do.
Because it kind of hadn't been tried out.
But I don't have a magic solution for it.
And I also don't think that optimistic science fiction actually makes anybody optimistic.
I don't think that helps with the problem at all.
I mean what makes people optimistic
is something to be enthusiastic about.
That's when people are really optimistic.
They don't even ask if they're in a good mood.
They just hop out of bed because they want to go do it.
We don't have a lot of things to be enthusiastic about.
Like Moore's Law was something
or the Internet was something.
But this is like your uncle's job now.
We don't have something that makes people
hop out and make it happen.
And if we did the oligarchs
would hit it on the head or buy it
or suppress in some way. And I think people know that.
So that's the actual...
what's the right word for it? Malaise.
That's the Carter-esque malaise of our era.
We're not authentic.